I'm Josh Brolin and this is Taylor
Kitsch this is the wired what was an
autocomplete interview how old is Taylor
catch Santa you know why you should do
like they do on IMDB you go I'm between
25 and 45 there you go between 25 and 45
years old how to pronounce Taylor teach
there you go how much does a Taylor
Kitsch weigh 240 no you don't know you
know you're trying to make yourself
sound more masculine than you are you
know everyday
what do you everything you just don't
care it's just all but you know I don't
know I don't yeah you do I'm just how to
get Taylor Kitsch hair so how do you get
such great it's a piece so you literally
buy it or watch that's a really secure
piece it's expensive but good by the
least googled question how does he
Taylor Kitsch get famous what's a bad
moment that you're most known for how
about that
probably epinephrine illa it's amazing I
talked to somebody about Friday Night
Lights the other day it was a woman and
all on the reaction was this that was
that on that no
we go where the money is all right the
number one I'm actually quite curious
there's no island really James Brolin
son is Josh Brolin in a Geico commercial
seeing the dude he's a full-blown
neanderthal like his Josh Brolin really
the monkey I got several of my movies
because of that Geico commercial it's so
insult Ronson is my dad it's not
James Brolin is Charles Bronson are we
related are you left-handed no okay it's
really playing cable I am King that's
why you're getting fat again that's why
I'm eating Donuts from here on out Oh
goddamn man seriously yeah I mean it's
my dad's chick another car let's keep
going does Taylor Kitsch have a wife all
right let's just leave out the a this
Taylor Kitsch have y- all right just
Taylor Kitsch have a tattoo
don't get all bottled up again loosen up
somebody man right now I've a tattoo I
do does Taylor Kitsch have siblings or
is all about you it still is all about
me but I have two older brothers and two
half-sisters very good that's a busy
family busy parents are busy while your
dad was there too I hope it was your dad
who does Taylor Kitsch look like this
you supposed to ask me that you
how are you related to elder brother I
could I think we could play brothers
honest right here we go we're getting
deep did Josh Brolin
skate and throw in thrashing yes next
the Josh Brolin plan ago yep Josh Brolin
have a son I do I mean we're like
banging through this how old is your son
29 how much was seven I was the Josh
Brolin way it fluctuates man I was 240
and then I always 162 40 well not right
now but close and I've been his light as
167 it was like so unnaturally worse
yeah like my arms are short my legs are
short my torso is really long my head is
really big I was like a Kmart special he
might have been on some with the balls
the one with the big head that's really
a shame yeah I got a coupon for that one